and she looked at me and she said oh
that's too bad
she goes because i could teach you to
vibrate faster
and i'm looking at her like what what
she's like
yeah she goes you're like i'm married
that's inappropriate right
i'm thinking close to that i believe
that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense on the show today
is
david meltzer he is former ceo of lee
steinberg sports and now
current ceo of sports 1 marketing which
he founded with hall of fame quarterback
warren moon
he's a gigantic public speaker and a
humanitarian
he's a truly wonderful human being i met
him a couple of years ago when i
shot an episode of elevator pitch and
he we just totally connected i actually
did his podcast
that day because he has his own and
we were sitting there going on and on
and on like diving in realizing how much
we had in common
and how our beliefs were so in line with
each other we were just
like in our own little zone and we're
getting yelled at to hurry up and wrap
it up because it had been like 30
minutes and i kept telling everyone to
go away because
we were having such a good time so it
was really nice to have
75 minutes um to really dive into these
topics and
um things that inspire both of us and
stories of you know you know stories sad
stories of where we came from and what
made us who we are today
and then also what inspires us moving
forward and how to craft your life how
to create
a foundation that launches you into a
life that you truly want
as opposed to just chasing something
that is either
never going to fulfill you because it's
from the ego or maybe let's just say
it's just
money which was his goal and guess what
if you want to make money you will but
then what do you
what are you gonna do after that so it's
about creating foundational
fundamental goals and principles that
are going to
fuel you for life so please enjoy this
episode
um so you grew up in a house with six
kids
we're laughing of course because you
said talk about my family and my
growing up and i'll cry so we'll start
there no problem
um but your mom single mom your dad
walked out when you were five
yeah um and one day
you saw your mom crying
and it was about money and you had this
epiphany that
money was what must buy you happiness oh
yeah
for sure so how did that shape your life
you know what's kind of cool is that
most people don't two bedroom apartment
with six kids five boys and a girl
but i was supe my mom was so
extraordinary that i was super happy
and so to see her unhappy because of
money
really like triggered me that i have to
make my mom happy because i lived this
extraordinary life
and she was such an educator worked two
jobs you know
literally got home from being a second
grade teacher filled up the turn styles
at 7-eleven
with greeting cards packed six kids into
a station wagon packed our lunch
a dinner sorry in a brown paper bag and
had the older ones read to the younger
ones and
i would literally just tell my siblings
who are all by the way parents wet
dreams
harvard penn columbia wow i i literally
thought
that i was a terrible student because i
got a b um they
ended up summa [ __ ] laude from these
schools and but i would tell them
i don't need to do that because i'm just
going to be rich and
i knew literally money would buy me
happiness and all i wanted
talk about unconscious manifestation i
just wanted to buy my mom a house in a
car
because most the time she was sad is
because she literally didn't like the
places that we lived in
and we never had a nice car and it would
break down and we never had enough money
to fix it so
that's where i think my chip on my
shoulder started
was that i didn't feel like i was enough
because everyone else
i felt like looked down on me because
they had nice houses and nice cars and
my family
all were doctors and lawyers my mom had
too much pride to ask for help and i
always felt like
the underclass citizen wherever i went
so do you remember it do you remember
some things early on that you did
to try and make money oh yeah yeah um
once you know you black out things but
when i was
five years old i was really fast uh i
don't even remember being five
i i remember because like my dad left
and like i remember thinking in my head
i'm gonna be the man of the house
like at five what is this so with the
six of you what is it a middle i'm
middle high
so okay and girls boys one boy one girl
five boys okay um still you want to be
the man of the house i want to be the
man of the house okay
you know my older brothers were you know
very academic they like to play the
piano
like to read and study so i really felt
like i loved sports
and i always said i had one gift and i
could run scared really fast
and ironically the first job i had was
there
i literally grew up where lebron james
grew up in akron ohio
at this age and it was not a nice
neighborhood um i was the minority
in the neighborhood but i remember
people giving me something to
run up to the lawsons which is a
convenience store and getting five
dollars for running
stuff up there okay you started hustling
yeah and i really at five or six i
didn't really know what i was doing now
i know what i was doing
i probably was a good mule for them but
i really like money and
even throughout uh high school i would
do
sales type of things really sell stuff
that we had or i could find
and then it's funny because the only two
real jobs i had in college
i was playing football but i had no
money so i got a job selling
encyclopedias
because you could do it at night one
appointment at 6 pm one appointment at 8
p.m
and they sold leads to people that just
had babies and you would go in
and because i had an academic family my
story was
hey you want to be like my family they
all went to harvard penn columbia
but my mom read to me since i was in the
womb so
you know for 45 a month for 18 years
you know at 18 interest you could have
to go to harvard
yeah pretty much yeah these books come
in pretty much the encyclopedia and the
you get the free bookshelf but it was a
lot of money and i was good yeah they
were expensive back in the day when we
we had one growing up yeah people here
you know these young kids are probably
like
what's an encyclopedia can you imagine
now like trying to do
reports without the internet and having
to go to an encyclopedia britannica
and look up things like there's no way i
mean it'd be interesting to know what
fraction of information was actually
contained within the encyclopedia set
versus what's on the internet
and what was correct oh sure right yeah
well what's correct on the internet too
that's a good question yeah that's good
question and
progressing to law school it's funny
because all these little things led to
me getting that first job that i made
millions at but in law school
i needed money so i always have woken up
my mom's
parenting philosophy was pretty simple
number one i always joke around that
she was a black belt of the martial arts
i made actually
uh what's his name damon wayne's fall
out of his chair cause i said because he
does martial arts like oh my mom's a
black belt
he was really i go yeah third degree
black belt and jewish guilt
and that was really her key to success
but also she woke us all up at five
o'clock her philosophy was
am yeah i don't care what you do just
you got to wake up at 5 00 a.m and you
can stay out as late as you want do
whatever you want
knowing that you know trust me you did
not make it past
nine so we were really good kids in that
respect
i agree with that philosophy dad woke us
up like my sister and i
summer break i mean obviously with
school you'd have to get up early but in
summer break
he would call the house at eight a.m not
five a.m but eight a.m
until we answered until we answered he's
like get up and do something with your
day
and to this day i mean i wake up excited
for the day i look at my phone to look
at what time it is because
that's the only clock i need now and so
i look at my phone
and i just hope it says something with a
six on it because i want to get up i
don't want it to say five something so
i'm like
shoot i'm kind of awake now i gotta go
to sleep and then there's those other
people
who you know they look at the clock and
no matter what they wish they had
another hour or two and i don't i want
to get going
and i wonder if there's something to
that waking up that
that you know that molding of you at
such a young age going get up do
something with your day
i i truly believe there is because i
believe there's two mindsets
you know you're a mindset person like
myself and most people don't realize
that we only have one action in the day
and so at a very young age what my mom
was programming us to do
is to have the mindset of that first
action is going to be a positive action
right and so today i still wake up at 4
a.m
and the reason in law school i got my
job was i could sell
road runner sports tennis shoes incoming
sales 4 am to 9 am
then go get my law clerk job 9 a.m and i
make more money selling shoes than i did
law but
i believe that mindset's so important
because for now
my life has changed as we'll go through
but i believe that mindset is to find
peace
and then that's the one action of the
day the rest of your day is just
reaction
so you're really only allowed one action
because once you take action everything
else that happens in your life is a
reaction
so the two mindsets i have is find peace
and then get back to peace or get back
to center how do you find peace in the
morning then what do you do
it's funny because i used to say that i
pray and meditate right 20 minutes a day
i meditate to find peace
although today i got a piece of advice
that now that i'm over 50 it's
ppm
and since i'm over 50 it actually i
think is more peaceful to take a pee
than
well you know the dalai lama actually
said he likes to eat before he
before he meditates because otherwise
he's just distracted by being hungry and
i'm like
i can relate it's awesome now i'm a
hundred percent certain i don't meditate
as much as the dalai lama
but uh yeah p pray meditation yeah and
that philosophy and mindset that you
know i'm plug i'm a lamp
okay and i'm plugged into the highest
source of energy i try to tell people
and i know you're going to have another
guest is going to talk about that you
have more power in one finger i mean
enough power in this finger to light
this house up for a week and we don't
realize the extraordinary kilowatts that
we carry and
you know people are confused they always
are talking about i gotta connect to
inspiration i got to find my purpose
no no no you need to clear the
interference away from what you're
already connected to yeah find it in
here including here
like you and i talked and there we when
we were doing our tv show together
i felt so con there's so much power and
then other times there's interference
and so i really dwell on the two
mindsets of i'm going to be at peace
enough center and find that power
and when i get off of center and ego
based consciousness
my goal is just to get back to center
before i start any type of movement
again
well i definitely believe that when you
wake up in the morning let's say you
know you drop your toothbrush or you
stub your toe or something
and you're like oh it's just it's a
horrible day it's just going to be a bad
day well that's exactly what you're
going to get and so for many years i've
thought of it like that going now when
something like that happens
i just laugh and i'm like huh oh and i'm
not going to say
it's going to be a bad day because
that's exactly what it's going to be
then
another thing that i feel like i've been
thinking about more and more is how
again i said you know wake up and look
at my phone to see the time
that phone right it's just one of those
one of those things that can be used in
such a great way but it can also be so
distracting and so consuming
and create so many negative thoughts and
so
i've also been thinking about how when i
get up in the morning
while i might look at a text message
from someone that i love
i won't look at social media i'm not
going to like lay there and look at my
phone
i'm gonna wait until i get downstairs
have some water
make my coffee and then go okay and just
like start my day with some peace
like you said because now i'm not
disciplined enough to sit there for 20
minutes and meditate at first but
but i'm at least getting more
disciplined to sort of say like i'm
going to remove
outside influences from my day so that i
can just start rolling in the right
the right way that's really cool you
said rolling in the right way because i
talk about
when we're in that ego based
consciousness people say well how do you
get back to center i'm like
your mind body and soul are on fire when
you're in the
ego based conscious that's the need to
be right offended fearful and anxious
you're creating all this so you say well
i'm always like my mom taught me if i
catch on fire to stop drop and roll
yeah so that's what i do i have taught
myself to stop
i drop down my blood pressure i get back
to center and then i make sure i just
roll in the right direction again
which is interesting that you said that
and one of the things about waking up
before though which
i find unique so i'm one of the few
people that actually does it religiously
i
live my today so i can wake up tomorrow
at four and that's what it takes to wake
up at that time
you can't just condition yourself you
have to actually live your life thinking
okay if i do this am i to be able to
wake up before of course right
but the cool thing is you won't need
there's no pressure time wise when you
wake up that early
nobody's expectation is you're going to
get back to them my biggest problem is i
finish meditating at 4
20 i have 10 minutes i go work out my
problem is
i'll look at my text like before i get
in the car or whatever and sometimes
i'll forget that it's four
and i'll text somebody and what if their
ringer you know how it lights up and it
wakes them up
and they're like what the heck is he
doing so considerate see here i'd be on
the other side thinking
gosh they're going to think i'm so
ambitious today
right when you answer like a little too
i don't know you are ambitious i'd be
like of course you did that
i'd like to think so but okay so uh
you you said you got this amazing job
you made a whole bunch of money you're a
millionaire in your 20s you're a
multi-millionaire in your 30s
everything's going great and then your
dad sends you something
yeah my first warning so you know i
really were you thirty thirty thirty
years old so my dad left
and he was my hero so this will be when
i cry because i try to make it through
the story but it's hard because
my dad was my hero so imagine this back
in the 70s
there really wasn't a thing about child
support most dads were deadbeat dads no
matter how much money they made so
here's my father good looking rich
leaves my mom with these kids
and he goes and finds a new wife that's
closer to my age than his
driving his convertible cadillac in fact
one time he drove by
he was supposed to take me out and waved
um
literally with this beautiful blonde
lady but
i still he was my hero like and i
actually said to my mom
why can't you be more like dad you're
such a loser
um and she was working two jobs yeah and
she would never
uh say one thing negative about him
right which
today still like i tried to aspire to be
to that potential of
unconditional judgment where she could
be that peaceful to do that but when i
was 10 years old
my dad forgot my birthday and i was
crushed
and i started to cry and i'm like how
could he forget my birthday because i
literally felt as if i was my dad's
favorite i was the most like him
right i was a bullshitter manipulator
overseller back-end seller
i was just like him and i i
called him up and this is where he made
his biggest mistake i said how could you
forget my birthday and he said i didn't
forget your birthday
i don't believe in birthdays and i was
smart enough at 10
to realize that my dad just bullshitted
me right he didn't care about me
and it it crushed me i would rather him
say hey
you know i was busy i really love you i
made a mistake
but now that i'm a father i know why he
lied
because he was so hurt and shameful but
i literally turned the knob and also my
mom
turned on my father it was the first
time she ever said anything negative
about him and she probably shouldn't
have
but she knew how crushed i was so i
lived and she was protecting you at that
point of course and i was crushed and i
i literally went to hate and i'd
separated myself from him
i would tell him i don't want to be
anything like him he moved to houston i
didn't want to visit him
they forced me to go visit him um and i
i always made up stories about my father
to my friends
like i made up these stories about a
father i didn't have because i moved to
san diego
and so they nobody ever knew my father
so i made up these like great stories
about my father and when i was 30 years
old my dad never ever said he was proud
of me
even to the day he died that's tough
that's rough never
and at 30 he gave me this big box and it
came
and it was a birthday present and i
thought wow my dad gets it he's
finally turning the corner yeah and so i
get this wonderful blazer
and it fits me perfectly which meant
more than anything because at that time
i could afford what i wanted but it fit
me which many asked my wife
my sizes had it custom-made you know
because i don't have
you know the perfect off-the-rack body
and i opened it up and he tore all the
the lining out and the pockets out and i
i was like
this guy is sick right like literally he
sent this as some
sort of sadistic joke of teaching me
something and i'd
so i called him up and i'm like dad i
got your birthday present
i'm like but i can't wear it he goes
it's not for wearing
like what is it for he goes for hanging
in your closet i'm like why
to remind you of me and i'm like what
that you're an [ __ ]
you know literally and he goes no you're
just like me and i literally got upset
i'm like
i'm nothing like you i'm a father
right i have three daughters i've worked
my butt off
i've made everything myself i was right
and i i was
so angry and i'm like i'm nothing like
you said you're just like me and i want
this to remind you of me
so you don't end up like me i go what do
you mean he goes i don't want you to be
the richest man in the cemetery
i want that to remind you you can't take
anything with you
when you're gone and that to me was the
first warning sign that i was just like
my father the reason i hated my father
was just like my father
everything i hated about my father was
what i hated about myself
well because when there's anger
associated there's something deeper yeah
exactly and that shift a couple other
things occurred to put me
you know into the right direction which
is funny because i had everything i ever
wanted
my best friend we went golfing i asked
him how come he don't hang out with me
he said because i don't like who you
hang out with
and i'm like well i'm not doing what
those guys are doing you know you can
hang out with me and he literally said
which shook me he said you can lie to me
but don't lie to yourself
and i stayed up the whole night after he
said that to me because i knew it was
true that's powerful
i was partying i was going places that i
shouldn't go
and it was funny i would go places that
you shouldn't go
and then the whole time regret being
there like in my head
and i don't and i did it habitually like
out in the middle of the day like
self-sabotaging yourself
yeah and like literally you go like why
am i here this is not me this is
and then finally i had gotten a job at
lee steinberg
uh you know i went through a transition
in technology from you know we sold our
first company for
3.4 billion to thompson reuters which
sent me into a trajectory
into the silicon valley which ended up
being a ceo of the world's first
smartphone
i mean i was midas in my own mind midas
like i controlled and i was super happy
in my mind like even buying my mom a
house in a car i'm like oh bought me
happiness i'm my mom's favorite kid
like everything was money or so you
ended up doing that oh yeah
how did that feel when it actually
happened amazing and that i mean it just
cemented the fact that money bought
happiness i was convinced
that it was that it bought happiness and
money was so important to me i used to
talk only about money
my whole valuation was about money i
didn't even realize how lost i was in my
own ego
to prove something to somebody about how
rich i could be
and the last warning was i had gotten
this tremendous job with lee steinberg
because
of money he jeff morad had bought into
the diamondbacks had left him
he was looking for a successful because
he didn't care about money i
love it or i think small world yeah yeah
and i
literally was the new jeff moran de lee
and i came home i was with little john
the rapper at the grammy awards i'd lied
to my wife about going
and i came home at five in the morning
in an altered state of mind
and she's built just like you same size
and i see that
tiny silhouette with the four car garage
and the glass
doors and i'm like oh [ __ ] like
literally
my friend even asked you sure you don't
want to spend the night i'm like she
sees us dude
i can't leave now because i'm drunk i'm
like she sees
us anyway like a five-year-old i walk up
there and she literally asks me she goes
or told me she goes you
you are not a rock star and i looked at
her i go i may not be but i sure feel
like one oh my gosh
yeah well this is what i was told
because she did not want to see me i
came down in the morning completely
hungover
and to a crying wife who is the most
extraordinary person best friend
enlightened spiritual told me like she's
just awesome
and she told i've known her since the
fourth grade i adored her and she
literally
said you know i'm not happy you better
take stock in who you were and what you
want to become
or you're going to become very lonely
and
wow i'm one of the few people i
literally was scared straight
i went back and outlined these certain
things
way to live my life that set me on a
different trajectory
and the hard part for me to explain to
people is it took two years
of a quantum shift in my life a
transformation
while i was learning and growing i went
bankrupt two years
after i went through my quantum shift
yeah i'm curious about that because it's
really weird
you've obviously set the wheels in
motion in a whole nother direction
for the long term versus the short term
but it resulted in
losing everything yeah i created causes
and i really believe that life is about
lessons and the lessons are going to
keep on coming until we learn them
and the way we know i agree completely
literally and
sometimes you have to go completely
broke yeah you don't have to get to that
point but
sometimes there's bobbing out the best
thing that you can do and so how'd that
happen
you know what happened is i'm and that's
why i wrote my latest book right game
time decision making
i made bad decisions based upon
assumptions
i surrounded myself with the wrong
people the wrong ideas but what happened
was
my ego i got into a lawsuit with a
neighbor that i bought a condo
conversion from and i spent millions of
dollars of cash
proving i was right oh wow right as a
lawyer that's really dumb but
the interesting thing my wife lawyer is
really happy he made a ton of money oh
they all did
you lost a lot but i always the lawyers
get paid no matter what
exactly right and remember that if
you're going to get divorced too which i
have not or no what will i do
but divorce lawyers especially what was
interesting for me though
is that i literally always felt like i
had at least 40 to 50 million dollars i
could fall back on
because i owned 33 properties i had a
ski mountain
a golf course with tons of equity but
because i was so arrogant
i never asked for help right and that's
a lesson that i've learned
but i went to my private bank and i said
hey i need another 5 million
and they said hey great where are you
going to get it i said oh i'm just going
to refinance this property i'll take a
line
uh no you won't i'm like well what do
you mean i want i got like 40 million or
50 million dollars in equity
you're not gonna give me five million
i've been a good customer of the bank
they're like well we're kind of going
under ourselves we rather hold your
property
than extend credit to anyone else we're
just not extending credit on property
anymore we're nearly not sure about
the valuations you know it's too high of
a risk for us at this time go somewhere
else
that's when the lessons started coming
right because i still had cash needs
and things were moving quickly word gets
out you're looking for money and the
properties
can't be evaluated fast enough because
they're having problems because
everyone's moving and before you needed
a pulse to get a loan
now it was like state stated income nah
we can't really look at stated income
right you know well your salary's not
that high at least steinberg's
yeah well i didn't need a high salary
right this was a different
and i have equity out of this and so
then you start selling things
and they're not selling fast enough and
you still have bills well then all of a
sudden you miss one payment
yeah then try to get a loan okay so
things
over a hundred i had over 100 million
dollars uh in
value right on paper over 100 million
dollars that i lost
and i remember the greatest piece in my
life
was the day that i literally went
bankrupt but not because of the clean
cleansing of bankrupt i actually didn't
owe anybody any money because i had so
much equity
it all just worked itself out but the
hardest thing was when i went bankrupt
i had gotten my job based off of me
being a successful business person and
being
wealthy and being able to raise money
and make money and worse lee steinberg
especially
at that time we did article in sports
illustrated he created legacies for
athletes 75
of all football players for example went
bankrupt two and a half years after
playing
and here his ceo was bankrupt how's that
going to look right
so i was terrified telling him i thought
i was going to lose my job
and no warren moon who's not my business
partner
but him they both were really supportive
but here's the worst thing
where's where i found my piece as i was
driving home i realized
i had to tell my mom and my mom was that
person who always was doctor lawyer
failure
don't take big risks study hard work
hard get a normal job like my siblings
did
she said the internet wasn't gonna work
out too right yeah yeah right i had that
job offer that made me money but imagine
going to tell your mom
who you think loves you because you
bought her a house in a car
who you think loves you because of your
financial success that was the only
thing that distinguished me from these
extraordinary siblings
which really has an energy the
five-year-old story of like
money equals happiness yeah imagine
having to tell her that you went
bankrupt but moreover
i realized i didn't take her house out
of my name
so i lost her house oh [ __ ]
yeah so i'm crying holy crap all the way
over to her house
oh my god and i'm in my mind i if anyone
ever saw red fox when he used to be like
elizabeth
like remember my mom's drive was jewish
guilt i thought
what does jewish guilt look like i don't
know it's yeah that's right well it's
guilt in general right it was like
how could like i'll give you an example
of a parenting jewish kid okay uh
i got into a fight with my younger
brother and we're pounding each other on
the floor and my mom would sit there
crying saying you're hurting me more
than you're hurting each other
please i've done everything for you
right that's jewish guilt in a classic
way or just telling you you know doctor
is this just any guilt like just like
any guilt or is it
specific to jewish life i think jewish
guilt you know like maybe the catholic
stronger catholics invented it and
jews perfected it but it's there it is
yeah
but i literally thought like she was
going it was gonna break my heart
in hers yeah and so i went up told her
that
i had lost everything and including her
house and she would have to move
and without blinking without crying
without any guilt she looked at me and
asked me if i was okay
if she could help me give me any money
she
i was like how could she be it was like
the mom
that i sat there telling her you know
you're such a loser
there was the person that like set forth
that trajectory for my life
and i looked at her and i was already on
the spiritual path
and i said that's what the truth looks
like right
and i wanted to now enjoy that pursuit
of the truth
my potential i wanted to be like my mom
but i was given different gifts than my
mom my mom's a catalyst
i'm actually a producer and i wanted to
change lives through
making money and at that moment i
realized one thing that money was super
important not to my mom but to me
not because it bought happiness because
it allowed me to shop
and what if i changed everything in my
life and started shopping for the right
things
and this is where the paradigm is really
cool is that i'm different than most
spiritual people
i'm a money-oriented pragmatic
spiritual person thinking grow rich is
one of my favorite books i think that's
important for people to hear though
because money is not evil
no it's it's why you're doing it or what
you're doing
with it perhaps but money's not evil it
can be wonderful
it's an energy right energy so please
how about people understand how they can
have
a positive association with money
instead of thinking that it's
you know like they try and tell you the
root of all evil no it's not
it's an energy they ask for if it's the
root of all evil why do they come around
with a plate asking to put money in it
okay so let's clear this up because
you're shopping for the right things and
so for me
money was an object that i could put
into the flow it's truly the pragmatic
example of how we manifest
i've actually to help people understand
manifestation because that was a woo
term that i like people that manifest
stuff are high
broke sick on their mom's couch lazy
right
that was how we thought of it before
yeah and so like i'm like money's a
manifestation like if i have
a green card i can manifest so much if i
have a platinum card i can manifest so
much on amazon if i have a
black card i can manifest everything
well i was gonna take that philosophy
the energy that you put into the flow
and i was gonna shop for the right thing
so like my 50th birthday
i decided i'd shop for two community
centers in africa and see
what that provided which was happiness
but then i realized there was some
a greater currency in the universe than
money and a pragmatic money
is a pragmatic level money's important
faith
now faith always scared me because i
wasn't religious okay and i
love people who have faith because you
are someone who i use an example that
have extreme faith why
because it's someone that can think say
do and believe something
and affects their unconscious competency
your personality traits your
characteristics your obsessions and
addictions
created a frequency at such a high level
that you were able to exceed
what anyone even believed right and and
i see it all the time i've been blessed
to be a sports agent and to be in media
i see people that have continually
enjoyed
the consistent persistent pursuit of
your potential when i was with you one
of the most interesting things
i'm like oh you must love to race and
you're like no no
you learned to do it and people tell me
all the time you're so lucky every job
you loved every job you had i said
who would love selling legal research
right honestly
i learned to love everything yeah it's a
mindset i learned to love what i do
because i enjoy the pursuit of my
potential the bipro
like these are just like byproducts of
getting to an end goal
really they're just like a part of the
path you know absolutely and
money is a catalyst for allowing you to
enjoy the pursuit of your potential
at even a greater level you just have to
shop for the right things but with
faith it's even cooler because if we
think say
do and believe every day consistently
and persistently
yeah the universe is a bigger amazon
right i call it the field of intention
it's a bit and i want to hold it bigger
amazon i love that yeah
imagine having a black card of faith
where you think say and do things at a
statistical pace
that everything you think say and do and
believe comes to you
right it will your ideas will clothe
itself
i don't understand why people think that
if i plant a corn seed
in the ground we're never surprised when
corn comes out but when i plant a seed
and imagine it
of imagination in my brain why am i
surprised with what you put faith in
right comes out right when i think about
what i want
if here's what happens if you don't
think about and put faith in what you
want
you're going to be a copy right because
what other people
and we put faith in what other people
want for us then we resent when we get
it
but everybody else when you ask them
what you should have or do
all they're going to do is copy right
they're not going to have any original
thought for you
so you're going to end up a copy if you
put faith in what everybody else wants
for you
it takes danica patrick to put faith in
something completely different
and everyone says no no that's
impossible if jeff bezos 25 years ago
was sitting in his garage told me
he'd be worth a hundred billion dollars
because he's starting an online
bookstore
i'm an imaginative guy but if he put
faith in what i believed he would not
have 100 billion
yeah right believing is 100
the most powerful that was to me my
career like there's no reason why i
should have become a race car driver i
didn't have the name i didn't have the
money i didn't have that i had no job
when i was 20 21 years old when i should
have like that was
a pivotal part of my career but all i
did
was i had tons of blind faith that's
what i always called it even when i was
younger
i just knew it was going to work out i
just totally believed it was going to
work out
it is literally the most powerful force
i believe there's three laws that people
get confused and once again you're a
perfect poster child for it
first there's the law of goya which john
asrov talks about
one hard work okay right you are a hard
worker yeah
smart work you're a smart worker and
then long work
which is something that gary vaynerchuk
and i talk about is
we're long workers meaning we have a
long perspective we don't
attach you know you're 21 everyone's
saying you're crazy
i'm looking way out here i'm a long
worker then you have
the law of attraction which is the
belief right i'm going to plant the
seeds get what i want
but the thing that most people don't
understand and you are a poster child
for this
is the law of surrender where the most
successful people are
not only do they live by the law of goya
and attraction
the law of surrender states this that i
have enough faith
that i'm going to surrender to
get out of my own way surrender to my
ego surrender to all those people that
make me insecure
fearful everything all those words
the people that live in the law of
surrender are not listening to those
voices either outside their brain or
inside their brain
that says you can't do it no one's done
it before
you're gonna lose everything no one's
gonna like you one of my favorite
garyvee stories when i was with them
last friday was
yeah i went to the eighth grade and i
started trying to sell
uh baseball cards the girls and my
friends were like you blew it dude your
whole
rap is over for high school you did in
your first day of the eighth grade he
goes i was a long thinker
and i surrendered and put faith in what
i wanted
and that's how he was successful you
know there was uh
aubry marcus said it really well when i
was expl like explaining this
i listened to a lot of abraham hicks i'm
not sure if you do or not but
this is sort of how when you want
something enough
you also create resistance and so he
explained it really well and that
when you want something so badly
and you have desperation which that's
not surrendering right
then on the other side of it because
there's always the balance of it the
polarity of the other side it means that
you're very
you're so frightened that you won't get
it so that has energy too
the fear of not being able to do what
you need to do
make the money you want to make be who
you want to be so
the surrender comes to release all
of those conflicting energies and
let what is already in motion just
flow absolutely in fear we had talked
about earlier
it's so interesting being around
athletes that will tell you what fear
motivates me
i'm going to tell you this
mathematically and aubrey will agree
fear is the most depreciating thing you
can do it'll suck your soul of all your
energy where people get confused about
fear
is fear focuses us and let me explain
with the best example
i've seen an old lady a grandmother lift
a car to save a baby out of fear
out of fear not out of inspiration
out of fear what she did was got so
hyper focused that
her body biochemically created a
reaction that created
ultimate strength for her what you don't
see that happens to people
is after she lifted that car she had
torn ligaments and muscles and was sore
her back was out there's all these
physical manifestations of what happened
because it depreciated all her energy
right there's no sustainability to fear
other than depreciation of all your
energy
so what do we have to do in order to be
happy is we have to find a substitute
for fear to be focused right how do we
get clear balanced and focused
through consistent behavior why you are
a great athlete
is you are consistent every day
persistent
in the pursuit of your potential as a
racer as a driver but
literally in my life people ask you
what's the closest your potential
ironically
the closest i came to my potential was
because when i was five years old i
wanted to be a professional football
player
every day of my life i was focused in on
that i had a knowing about me
that i could play football even though
every team i ever joined i was the last
one picked they always were third on the
chart
even when i started in college when i
came back for the next year
i was third on the chart there was
always some freshman that was going to
come in that was twice my side whatever
yeah and you know literally even though
i was an
average division three football player
that's the closest to my potential i've
come
according to my talents yeah that has
helped me more than anything because
i've been given gifts that i
wasn't utilizing and so now that i can
speak and process and write and all
these things that i'm really good at
and now i'm applying i wish i would
apply when i was five like you did
driving but even though i started
approaching some of them at 25 35 and 45
there's no rush to it i told you yeah
you know bob proctor uh
napoleon hill who's one of my favorite
authors carnegie sat down and said
if you're going to work for me and
travel the world and learn lessons and
be more impactful than i can
you need to read this every day for 30
straight days and it said i
napoleon hill will challenge
andrew carnegie at the post and beat him
at the finish line
and he didn't believe it at all and so
for me
i look at my mentors and i went up to
bob proctor
yeah he's one of my thought leader
mentors and i said as
we were speaking on the same stage i
said hey bob i'm going to challenge you
at the post and
ask yeah he did he goes you may have
already done it i said no
you're 35 years older than me and you
know
literally what you've accomplished and
my goal is to
literally impact a billion people to be
happy
yeah i mean like i want to talk about
that i mean obviously you know you went
through that
huge transition in your life the sort of
the quantum shift the frequency shift
and what became like what did you
identify as your reset button like this
is how
i'm going to identify with the world
according
according to me but in business what
identified was three worlds that i had
lived in
the first was a world of not enough um
so when i grew up
i was in a scarce mode there was never
enough and i
was a victim i was born poor born with a
single you know
into this divorce family with a lot of
problems and i was just a victim and
then
when i proved i could make it i felt
like i will
lived in a world of just enough and
there was just enough for me i was
thought it was a very positive world
that there's always enough just for me
and just enough
but i wanted more there's always more
money more things more for you
yeah more for me and then as i went
through the quantum shift i realized i
had no motivation or worth
for me i sat when i built my huge home
in rancho santa fe i remember lying in
bed going
oh shoot you know what am i going to do
now it was the first time
whatnot happy yeah right there's a whole
bunch of that because
you know the ego is never full ever the
eagle is always hungry
yeah no matter what you accomplish it's
it's when it's
ego based it's it's never full
yeah one super bowl is not enough no
yeah although before the super the
manchester i'll tell you what's up
nothing's enough no and then i realized
there's this world of more than enough
what if i lived in true appreciation and
i don't just mean being thankful for
everything that came to me
but what if i added value to it and gave
it away
how motivated and inspired would i be if
i could
allow myself to expand and accelerate to
the point where i could handle or have
the capacity to attract
more than anyone else and allow it to
come through me add value to it and give
it away i called it
the 120 rule i was going to live my life
where i was going to be able to
give a hundred dollars to everyone that
i met and only ask for 20 back i believe
there has to be a flow
it wasn't just about giving it was
creating this flow
and i would do it emotionally i would
lie in bed and dream that my whole room
was
full of hundreds and i was gonna hand
out i wanted to know what it felt like
so i dream all day like anyone i meet
what their faces would look like
as you well know joe who i'm going to
talk to after you joe dispenza
how there's no difference in
there's no difference in your brain
between something that actually happened
and something that you've just imagined
so you've literally created those
experiences for yourself
and the energetic yeah nuance in fact i
actually
in my first book talk about cancel
clearing and connecting because people
have so much problems
oh yeah letting things go so i'm like
yeah negative thoughts yeah like what if
it comes back i'm like that means it's
in the subconscious so just tell
yourself clear
yeah and then they say well you know
i've had these horrible things happen to
me
and i just can't let it go and so i
actually teach them to shift their
energy by
viewing what bothers them the most
finding a light in it which is a really
important progress yeah
you can find light and yeah you hate
right in other words pray for their
happiness
so the guy who i felt was the cause of
me losing everything the lawsuit the one
who took and was a very abusive and
attacking sure you held out animosity
for a long time nine years
and my wife still does actually she's so
honest but i literally
i started picturing him in my mind and
picking out the things that i knew he
really was that was good like he's a
really good dad
right he he was a he was really good dad
and
i take that light and i cover him and
then i look over here at my family that
i love the most
and i take that light between what i
hated the most and what i love the most
and then i put it over myself and i
actually
felt an energy shift and it took me nine
years to condition that
in fact i'm practicing right now
intuition
the same way that i practice shifting my
energy because i think intuition
is so interfered with that we have great
intuition how do you what do you mean
so like you know you know oh somebody's
calling i'm about to call you
or okay i knew you're gonna say that or
i knew that was gonna be 30 minutes okay
okay okay so you're like more you like
pushing for the manifestation of the
intuition yeah
a little extra is that what you're
saying yeah and so bob proctor one of my
mentors
because he is an intuit he can tell
things about people
and i said well how do you practice that
yeah and he's like dave
and i've been starting to do it it's
really cool yeah go into a room
and start staring at someone's back
that's not facing you and watch how long
it takes them to turn around and feel
you and then when they turn around go
hey he said
when you get really good at it when
you're sitting on a plane stare at the
crack between the seats
and watch all of a sudden they start
moving and literally
turn around and look through the crack
that's how you build that muscle of
intuition
wow allow people to feel you to work
that muscle of not only
allowing others to feel you but you'll
start feeling so of course the question
is is like on a sports level or
you know just anything that you're doing
at a very very high elite level with not
a lot of time to think
how much of that really is already
happening into it anyway is
there already the intuition you don't
know it you're just a good player
but you actually have a highly tuned
intuition
or for exactly or for me on the track
like
you know i had i told crew chiefs and
engineers all
all the time like i'm telling you it's
loose like if you want me to spin out to
prove it to you i will but i promise it
is
and so like how much of that was just
intuitive based versus
like you know actually yeah yeah
and i like to study film of running
running backs especially because i'm so
curious about intuition in the third eye
yeah they call it the third eye
it to confuse you and make it seem
woo-woo but it's just intuition
right you have five senses that are very
disturbed meaning
you do not see smell taste touch
correctly we all you know i learned this
in criminal law when i went to law
school it was
really fascinating my professor the
first day of law school
all of a sudden this guy ran in and it
said you gave me an f and attacked him
hit him and get and he ran out of the
room and then the professor got up
laughing
and he said okay i got up laughing what
a great professor it was staged
it was staged oh and so he got up
laughing and he said okay now everyone
i want you to write down how tall he was
if it was a man or a woman what color he
was what they were wearing what color
the shirt
all these different things and it was
amazing these are highly intelligent
law students it was amazing how off
everyone was
oh yeah which tells us our perception oh
yeah it's so far off yeah but our
intuition
can be exact yeah so i read this great
book
called frequency and um and one of the
sort of exercises it gave that i thought
was
wonderful was identify with something
that you have a judgment or a
problem and imagine the worst possible
outcome
imagine the worst case scenario worst
thoughts worst outcome
and feel how that feels then
shift to imagining the best possible
outcome and the best possible feeling
you could have
and feel that and now pick which one you
want to live with
pick which energy you want to like
infiltrate and
and and then extend beyond your body
right so
i feel like what you're saying when you
look at somebody and get them to turn
around
you're literally sending the energetic
signals the frequency of like
i want to engage with you hello i'm
friendly
look at me say hello because if you were
if someone's if you were standing behind
somebody and you just thought you're
horrible i hate you
i wish you'd die and you thought all
those things i can promise that person
probably walk away
as opposed to turn around and say
something to you so it's important to
understand that our thoughts
like our energy is felt right i think
joe depends also says it's like a
no no it's bruce lipton he's gonna love
when he says you know the because the
gazelle does not have to check with the
lion whether or not it wants to eat it
it knows absolutely i love going to
africa for that reason because there is
a different
sense yeah you know it's amazing i'll
walk a neighborhood and there'll be a
loose dog and i'll be afraid
but i've walked in the masamara with you
know wild animals
with no fear there's an intuition right
they don't you know and then you know
of course the guys will tell you they
can't even eat you so they're not
interested in
right you're way too big or they don't
even eat meat you know
so there's no need for you there's just
completely spiritual or energetic or
frequency
that creates this environment and that's
why i
love going to africa because you learn
so much about human nature
very much so and how do we truly inspire
people when we know
how how they feel frequency i i find i
mean i've i believe i actually
i actually believe that god is a
frequency oh for sure so when i i mean
that's one of my
first questions that really set me on
this more
um science-based spirituality
sort of quest was i was like what is god
not
not not who but like give me some kind
of explanation like it's not a dude on a
cloud in the sky with a throne and a
long white beard like that
it's not a singular person that's that's
that's that's not even fair to god
that's way too limiting
right he's just a man that poor him um
but no
but but i think of god as a frequency
for me so
you know one question that i have is
what
what do you do because no doubt like
life comes at you there are challenges
there are things that are going to make
you doubt yourself or
feel guilty or mad
you know there's all kinds of things are
going to happen but how do you raise
your frequency
yeah so for me there's three parts of
frequency one's the force of the signal
the strength of your signal
the bandwidth of your spectrum first
frequency so for example god has the
strongest signal
and the widest spectrum right he can
handle so many different channels
and then he has the greatest clarity so
for me those three things are very
important and i'll give you
a real life example how frequency works
in that respect
i wake up before i meditate immediately
then i take about 10 minutes to get to
the gym
saturday morning 4 30. i'm walking out
to my car and notice that my 17 year old
daughter's car is not there
[Music]
my frequency is off right i'm based in a
fear-based emotion and i
pick up my phone and i'm about to go
scream at her yeah right that's where
it's at and then i stop drop and roll
i get back to center and i elevate my
frequency
right i elevate so by literally going
back to center so i'm going back to the
place by breathing
okay by being aware of why so i ask
myself
why am i angry right that's the feeling
of ego that i have
why am i angry why am i so mad at her
because i'm afraid that one of the most
important people
to me is hurt yeah and i also have a
responsibility so i have my ego in the
way that
i've let everyone down because my 17
year old
car is gone and some things may be
happening break it down to the emotion
right instead of being angry about
something go it's because
i feel like i'm because i don't trust or
because i've been hurt or because
whatever it may be like break it down to
the energy that you can only be aware of
vibration
emotional frequency that is equal to or
less than you exactly if i can elevate
my frequency back
up here through going back to center now
i say to myself
okay okay my actual physiology is down
so i'm gonna pick up the phone again now
i call and i tell my
daughter this is one of the best
examples of of my highest frequency
time i called and i said hey where are
you
i'm in my room where at our house
where's your car it's at the grocery
store why
kids were drinking dad you told me
people are drinking that
not to have them in the car so i just
ubered home like you told me
oh okay i'm so sorry for waking you i
love you sweetheart
i love you too daddy no god what a
fantastic frequency
but here's the difference i could have
ruined my whole relationship and what
even worse than ruining my relationship
and creating all types of baggage
between and frequency interference
between the two of us
worse next time that that happens what
are kids going to do because they don't
want to be yelled at and swore at sure
they feel terrible they're going to get
in the car
with people that are drinking and then
something even
right it's a whole lower level of
vibration right and this is a classic
example of frequency where we cause so
much problem with ourselves
because we don't stop dropping well we
don't roll in that right trajectory
we don't understand vibration we don't
understand frequency and awareness
and the better now here's the cool thing
about lessons they're going to keep on
coming so you learn them
but i know one thing about them you're
going to forget every lesson that you've
ever learned at one time or another
yeah which means that no matter how
enlightened i sound yeah you sound on
here
you know that there's still times that i
sit there and go why would my wife still
be married to me that i just said that
right
what terrible daddy am i but i'm human
but the coolest thing about lessons to
me is you may forget every lesson you've
ever learned
but you have the power to remember them
all and i just want to remember
more and more and more that's a true
potential that i have is
what if i could remember to hold doors
open and to pick up trash and to put the
cart back where it's supposed to go and
to smile at people
and to not live in what if i remember
that more and more because all the
lessons we already know
them and the cool thing about frequency
is i can stand on a stage now
resonate so much that i can tell seven
thousand franchisees
change your life by being grateful say
thank you before you go to bed and thank
you when you wake up
and it has a frequency a power now a
signal and a spectrum and a clarity
that they'll stand in line for an hour
to an hour and a half
to tell me i changed their life that
they're now going to say thank you
you cannot tell me that they didn't know
that already it's a frequency
tell me some of the things that you no
matter how
silly because i have my own silly um
tell me some of the things that you have
found that you can observe being
grateful for
that you would have never like you never
were in that frame of mind
when you were in your 20s oh my goodness
so even 30s like where
where are you at now what are the simple
things that like just give us some
perspective as to
how rooted you can get and how joyful
you can get
in the simplest of things i literally
take it down to i am just thankful for
waking up
right i'm literally thankful for all the
people that i'm able to
impact like like weird things i'm
actually thankful for all the lessons
that i've learned which is
i think the most grounded thing that i
can say is i look at for example my
bankruptcy
and it took me nine years to truly feel
this but i am
so grateful for the mistakes because
they're all miracles like i believe
every set
back of mine is a set up and i'm
grateful for the setbacks
when i'm at my best and this is a really
hard thing for people to understand
when things get challenging i get
excited because i
truly am grateful that i know something
good is coming
i know it's counterintuitive like when
other people are like oh my gosh
you know there's a lawsuit and this is
happening and
the you know sky is falling i'm
literally at my best now that i put
myself in a place i'm like
thank you thank you because i'm gonna
learn and grow
like i know that this is what makes me
me this causes expansion acceleration
and growth
this is what makes a butterfly fly if
you cut open a cocoon
you kill the butterfly because its wings
aren't strong enough
it needs that and i don't know how i got
there through gratitude
but i have gotten to the majority of the
time
things do not phase me where the
embarrassing part for me is
i'm still a reactionary human being so
although the
big grand problems i'm super awesome at
doing that because it's so big my
embarrassment is
you know my daughter call calls and i'm
trying to get everything done and
whatever and i end up texting her please
don't text me i don't have time for this
right which reminds me of my favorite
deepak chopra story i met his daughter
and i was like
oh my god must be the best thing ever to
have everybody yeah
like imagine having a problem and going
into the study and be like floating all
day
right exactly and she's like what world
do you live in david i'm like
that has i mean deepak's your dad she
goes let me tell you i was bawling
crying i needed his help
and he's in there writing a book and he
looks up at me i'm crying david
and i go dad i need your help i need
your advice he goes stop bothering me
i'm writing a book go see your mother
and i'm like okay good deepak humans
he's human
well you know it reminds me of this um
because there have been lots of
transition especially in the last you
know
few years where i had to figure out like
how why and how i felt about it and
basically let me cut to the chase the
only way to the other side is through
and there is never growth without pain
period so the more pain you go through
be ready get excited just like you said
because you're about to break through
you're about to have a growth spurt
that is very difficult but you're going
to have to go through the pain first
right it's not you can't create a new
pattern without meeting the resistance
right
period you can't like you know you can't
have a new thought pattern without
training yourself you can't grow a
muscle without straining it like
there's no growth without pain right
that's why i keep saying right
lessons will keep on coming the only way
we know we're still learning the same
lesson is if there's pain
when the pain's gone you've learned that
lesson when the pain's gone you've
mm-hmm there you go for me and i think
those people that
have the ability to take that pain and
and somehow
turn it into that positive joy and you
see it mostly in sports right
and that's where i learned it that i
just have a higher paying threshold i
had a great kid on my podcast who has
one of the highest pain thresholds i've
ever seen he was a bmx champion
then he went into fitness in his first
fitness he won and
i think he set a world record uh on day
one of his fitness
but he actually like passed out and
almost died like
imagine push yourself that hard but he
had such a pain
he wanted to be a seal or something
but he's an extraordinary human being so
i know that
joe descends who you know spartan races
he's one that has a pain camp a
threshold camp because
with the youth today he feels like they
don't have enough growth potential
because they're
so everything's so easy right
everything's given to him so easy that
they haven't experienced the pain
so in their mind so he actually helps
him he says that
uh downhill skiers are have the highest
pain threshold they do the best in the
spartan races
because it's cold right it's hard
there's high levels
low levels of oxygen all which makes it
hard to cover too but it has the highest
threshold of pain that sport
and they do really well in the spartan
races um
so it's really interesting and you know
as you become older and maybe even
parent yourself that's the hardest thing
how can you allow your child to
experience pain knowing that
like i can do it for myself but my
hardest thing is to watch
them do it yeah i don't first you want
it you don't want to have it
which is cool because i think the god
relationship
right god relationship to me whenever i
get lost in that
i think to myself how would i feel about
my son
or my daughter what would i oh do you
think god wants us to be in pain
right he does it we're going all the way
to the top we all have
that's exactly what we want for our
child yeah yeah everything
he wants every ask any parent even the
ones that are disassociated
with they want everything for their
child that's where my confidence
lies in this whole manifestation of
faith is if what if i put
faith into a higher source that wants
everything for me
that i can really believe that and feel
it and do it and work
every because if you have full faith
it's not work i don't believe in work i
believe in activity you get paid for
right activity you don't get paid for
yeah and people that create resistance
by saying this is work
i feel sorry for yeah and we do live in
a society where there's so much of that
but
you know i feel like it's because let's
you know let's say the school system
right you go to college you have debt
then you have to pay it off you get
locked into your job you can't even take
a chance to not get paid for a while
because you have to eat you have to have
somewhere to sleep
it puts you into this horrible cycle
that you can't break free from
so you know we judge those who don't you
know we judge those who are
like free spirits and travel but they
don't have debt they're learning
they're growing and they're doing
something that they truly love
and i believe that you can make a job
out of absolutely
anything i mean i 100 believe that no
matter how remedial how silly it is
um i mean look at that one kid on on
youtube who gets like you know billions
of views to review
toys yeah i mean he reviews toys
so i think that it's fast and i think
that's like
i just think that that's that's a core
value is that you just have to find what
you love
there's also so i want to talk about the
four core principles
that you have because i think that
they're important because i think that
you know please tell us how they drive
your everyday life and your decisions
that you make
and and maybe some stories you have
about how you came to the conclusion of
like how
one of these made the list because
there's only four
yeah um and we'll start with gratitude
gratitude's my first one that's what i
took
these are the four things i wrote down
when my wife told me to take stock in
who i am wow
so the first thing i thought about and
how i came to it was i needed to change
my perspective
i had always grown up being grateful my
mom one thing she made us do
that's a good thing what do you mean you
have to change your perspective because
i stopped doing it oh
yeah i took a different perspective and
i started thinking i have to do
everything and my mom
you know when she programmed us right
before we went to bed
we had to say thank you for everything
we had
good not what we didn't have right and i
was just a little kid and then if we
went downstairs in the morning
and we weren't in a grateful attitude
she'd literally make us go back up to
the bedroom and come back and start over
right because she wanted to get it right
so gratitude to me was very simple
i needed to look at everything as i get
to do it which made
everything that happened in my past good
everything in my present better and
everything my future brighter simple
perspective
and i needed the mindset that i was
going to be grateful for everything that
came to me
i was going to make sure i appreciated
it what does appreciation mean it means
add value to it
so that was a really important part and
i figured it was the most powerful truth
that i could live by and i just was
going to be
grateful for my wife right i was going
to treat her you know it's so funny when
you're in an intimate relationship
i used to to think and joke but i would
say things that aren't nice about my
wife to my friends
right we all know the words that
husbands say and when i'd come home
that's what i would get
i now have an exalted queen the
beautiful
unbelievable woman that's literally what
i get right i choke up
i didn't think i cried about my wife but
i literally changed i
thought it's joke uh you might not know
teddy mellencamp and edwin
they're good friends he's on their
housewives but they've been married
about 10 years
and i watch them at dinner i'm like
these guys are just like me you know
they're bickering
and teddy said something my wife she
goes how often do you and dave argue she
goes i probably had two arguments
in the last 10 years with him and she's
like oh my god i want to what marriage
like that
he goes oh let's talk about the first 10
years two arguments a day
right because i started changing with a
gracious attitude i started putting
faith in what i wanted from people
finding that light you're going to get
more of what yeah i need to write that
down
all of you no you're right focus on what
you want not what you don't want
and out of people find that light and so
then it came to the next thing that i
wanted i wanted peace in my life so i
wanted
to be happy with perspective so that was
all that was
gratitude i could be grateful for
everything and everyone but
peace was powerful and i thought of
first
being sympathetic that was the first
thought that came to my mind i'm like
man if i could walk a mile in everyone's
shoes then i would be able to figure
this out and then i started thinking
you know what i cannot be sad enough for
someone to make them happy i can't be
sick enough to make them well and i
definitely can't be poor enough to make
them rich but what i can do is forgive
myself
and i knew one thing that i could only
give what i could i only get what i
could what i had
and forgiveness was so powerful and i
had so much
baggage that i had to learn to forgive
myself
or else my relationship with my wife my
family
everyone wasn't going to work yes it
will always come out the projections
will come and come and come
and the lessons will keep showing up for
you to learn that you first
have to forgive yourself you first have
to you have to say to yourself
you were you are not who you are were
then
you you made a mistake you you have
grown
you you didn't know any better or you
know like just
or you know better [ __ ] like get it i'm
sorry for being so hard on myself
i knew better and i still did it look
and what i've learned about that
forgiveness was
it allowed me to illuminate yeah and it
made other people
really love me yeah they weren't you
can't we people say all the time i love
how vulnerable you are dave
and i'm like because if you're
vulnerable you're invulnerable i've
taken all the steam out of it true
totally you give it all up front there's
nothing anybody can say yeah what are
you gonna say
i give it no energy and you know what
yeah and it won't bother me because i
forgave myself
yeah and it's not saying it doesn't give
me permission to do wrong things
right right but i can't stumble over the
roadblocks behind me
and it just makes actually i know it's
counterintuitive it actually secures the
fact that i won't do
because i've forgiven myself for
whatever reason energetically i won't do
the same mistake again
it's so weird to think about where you
take the power away people who don't
forgive themselves end up making the
same mistakes again and again just like
you said
it's so counterintuitive so gratitude
empathy forgiveness
then came the powerful one that came
from my mom is i was a really
accountable person
my mom would always tell me you're
living below the line in blame shame and
justification
because it was a bullshitter manipulator
overseller back-end seller and a liar i
could come up with all kinds of excuses
good salesman right and instead my mom
would hold me accountable
i want you to tell me dave i did this
ask yourself two questions what did i do
to attract this to myself
and what am i supposed to learn from it
right invoking the miracle to
mistakes to miracles lessons yeah and
that second one the interesting thing is
i go to law school
and i get really confused so i come home
with all these challenges to that
philosophy
what if someone hits me from behind at
the stop sign and
literally my mom had to teach me that's
liability and i teach other people this
ah people are still liability is
different that has to do with laws
right right and be liable but if someone
shall cancel hit me from behind cancel
if somebody would hit me i would
immediately still call my insurance
company
and i'd hold them liable sure but i
would go home and ask myself
what did i do to attract this person
what lessons am i supposed to learn
am i supposed to be more defense right
there's all these lessons i could learn
from an incident that
is causing me pain because i know it's a
lesson in there
and that's a true power so you know
gratitude gives you happiness and
perspective
forgiveness gives you peace
accountability is counterintuitive in
the fact that it gives you control of
your life
by surrendering and understanding i've
attracted this to myself what am i
supposed to learn from it
it i actually have complete control of
my life because
i know that i have the power to attract
whatever i want i have the power to
attract whatever i want
even unconsciously and if it comes that
way i have to learn from it
that way i get something from it and
then the last lesson
is inspiration yeah so i needed to live
an inspired life
and what happened was i only thought
that inspiration happened this way
by me selling people like i thought oh
you know like selling you putting
something out
yeah like me inspiring oh wow that's
funny because i would think
inspiration's like
somebody has to show me something so so
cool that i think i want to do that
isn't that funny
but for me it was i think it was the
manipulator the
like i felt that that was my power that
i could
you know inspire other people inspired
but the problem was i was missing what
you were talking about
i literally had no connection to that
which inspired me
right right it was all in a shallow
vessel that once i learned that
everything came through me
i immediately went this way which caused
me to go back to center which caused me
to meditate
and things and coincidences i'm a math
person these coincidences just started
happening
the most significant thing that took me
on my journey of
spirituality was i started on my
list yeah i saw the movie the secret
yeah
i poo-pooed it which means i didn't
believe anything my wife's like you are
the most resistant guy
and i'm like you can't sit in a chair
and get a ferrari
it took a lot of work but i in my 20s i
had a ferrari i love my ferrari
and then i learned to hate my ferrari
for various reasons
because it wasn't what i thought it
would be but it doesn't have a cup
holder wasn't it what the hell
i wasn't going to know literally i think
revealed my anatomy to all the girls i
was dating
i just had to get older and wiser to
figure that out but literally i
i i felt uninspired about everything
and if i learned to connect to that
which inspired me
my life would change and allow it to
come through me for others
and that those four things what did you
find inspired you then
my potential like truly the truth and i
went on an airplane
and this woman next to me looked at me
and she said you're so full of light
and i at that time literally just
started this quantum shift
i still had a lot of ego and a lot of
arrogance i was working for lee
steinberg
i was running the most notable sports
agency in the world my friends were the
most famous people
i still was rich and i looked at her and
i said thank you
and she said do you meditate and i
literally went into a diatribe and how
how long ago was this
this is like the two years before i went
bankrupt so i was thirsty
yeah i'm so excited somebody's talking
about meditating back then
yeah and her name was dr sangeeta sahi a
medical doctor
who was later i found a healer oh and
but anyway
she looked at me and said you meditate i
want to do this diatribe i'll
try to say it exactly but i looked her
and i said meditation meditation
i don't have time to meditate people are
high sick and broke on their mom's couch
meditate
i grew up oh god those are your words
not someone else's you were describing
them earlier like
they're people that are high sick and
broke no those are your words exactly
i'm telling her
straight out literally how could i
manage i made everything myself i
literally listed out what i had
oh wow ferrari a porsche like she's like
he needs to work on his narcissism oh
yeah yeah
i listed out like the ferrari the porch
the houses the ski mountain
golf course i run lee steinberg have you
heard elise steinberg ever seen the
movie jerry maguire
like this is where my ego was still and
she looked at me and she said
oh that's too bad she goes because i
could teach you to vibrate faster
and i'm looking at her like what what
she's like
yeah she goes you're like i'm married
that's inappropriate right so i'm
thinking close to that
i'm literally like this me a long flight
to india she goes the earth vibrates the
slowest then plants animals humans then
sound then light then thought
she goes do you know what vibrates the
fastest and i was literally still
arrogant i'm like no
she goes the truth and literally the
hairs
on my arms stood up she goes the truth
vibrates the fastest
you cannot be aware of anything that
vibrates right
just lower than you i can elevate your
vibration so you can be aware of the
truth
don't you want to know the truth i could
teach you whether to buy or sell
that's an awareness yeah and she invited
me to a workshop
you oh wow and i don't know why you take
the call i mean like did you go
i did wow and my wife had such
skepticism because i was so lost
i told her i'm staying in india an extra
few days to go to this workshop i met
this doctor saying
she thought i was going to a little john
concert right like literally
i was lying again and this was going to
be the end of my relationship she had to
google the woman
yeah to figure out she was truly a theta
meditation expert
wow healer wow a medical doctor wow
and i went through all these things like
including body scans past life
attracted her sitting next to you out of
doubt
and in fact i i still am a healer myself
i did my first body scan
and i remember it to a t where you know
someone gives you your hands and you
stay in their body for
energy and i'm not a believer at this
time
but i'm already getting to feel like wow
i'm pretty connected like this is really
true
and the woman that i was dealing with i
literally see all this red in her
stomach
and then on her right big toe it's like
a huge energy burst
and so you know dr saw he's like what do
you see david i'm like i see
you know red in her stomach and i see on
her big right toe
like this energy just swirling and i
open my eyes
because i can feel the lady go like this
yeah she goes oh yeah i'm having really
bad
stomach issues i've been to the doctor
on my medication and i stubbed my toe
this morning and lost my nail
on that big toe wow and i'm literally
like did i just do this like
where are you i mean i'm looking for the
skin right but this
is also a way that you know i found
whether it's myself or the people around
me that are
maybe mediums or something like that
like you do little tests on
people around you and then it develops
the
talent and you know further to trust it
more so that you can really start to use
it
law of surrender right and start being
aware of the power that we have we're
connected to
the greatest source of energy ever and
we can elevate our existence and
that set me on my way with those four
values now
just real quickly because i've added
three things that have changed my life
as i've evolved
it's been 12 years yeah the number one
thing
beyond those values is i think you know
we have this happiness
problem because people aren't humble
enough to ask
like if i would encourage anyone to
change their life i would teach this one
question do you know anyone that can
help me
like literally on average most people
know a thousand people
if we're asking every day just one
person we're increasing our chances of
getting help
and to expand 30 000 people renee brown
talks about this a lot about
when you ask for someone for help then
you know you're creating a connection
there's a trust there you know there's
that's like a
that's a connection point for sure and
so i'm a huge fan
and i still fight it there's several
situations that i
shouldn't ask i know we even talk about
the podcast they haven't asked when
someone comes in for you
i was with the cto of uber and we had
this great discussion
and i walked away kicking myself going
how did i not ask for help
that guy had tons of stuff he could have
helped me with and i didn't ask for help
the other two things one revolves around
time uh i think we have an infinity of
time people don't know how to utilize
time so
i always encourage people and i do this
i'm a student in my calendar i study it
with the lens of productivity and
accessibility
i want to provide as much value during
the day as i can i want to be accessible
to as many people
and access what i want and i think that
people if we get
really disciplined about being a student
of our calendar that we can understand
and take advantage of time
number one piece of advice that i have
for people is study the time that you
sleep
we sleep eight hours also family
incorporate that part too because that's
a
something you always have to think about
yeah family for me so i
lower the bar always i believe in
consistent behavior so family was
interesting because i had to shift
a different way than you would think
family was my priority then work
i had to put my health first so i do a
minimum
now and uh you know you can go back to
our elevator pitch days
what i look like then but i spend a
minimum of an hour a day on my health
so i will leave my son my daughters my
wife
every single day i don't miss a day an
hour a day minimum of my health
then my family and i even use the same
prescription with my family
and my relationships have never been
better my wife gets 30 minutes minimum a
day
undivided my undivided attention not
always whole could be 10 10 and 10.
but i don't go a day without spending a
minimum of 30 minutes a day with my wife
nine-year-old son minimum 30 minutes a
day three teenage daughters minimum of
two minutes a day
they're very intentional yeah very and
but my relationships and the best one
has been my mom
i give her a minimum of one minute a day
and i have something that i want to make
sure she knows
by asking her what makes you happy she
wants me to be happy
and i said what can i do to make you
happy be happy
and let me just know that you love and
appreciate me that's it that only takes
a minute every day
only takes a minute and i do it every
single day i talk about it almost on
every video
so sometimes if i can't talk to her i
literally send her that part of the
video just have my guys edit it
and i'm all hey i'm thinking of you text
her the link hey i'm thinking of you mom
and she's like oh my god you're with
danica patrick
and you told her that you love it right
yeah that's good we needed to send this
to her
exactly thank you what's your mom's name
karen
karen for being
such a shining example and you know it'd
be interesting to also know
how she got to the point where she could
be so positive so much the time
so maybe that should be her return video
to us it's like
how did you how did you stay so positive
because
it obviously affected you in a huge way
am i something's as well
and so you know i think that's an
important but i talk about sleep because
eight hours a day most people spend on
their subconscious and unconscious
without improving it
and that to me is a much more powerful
source and so
is there anything you do in particular
but we know we do what you do when you
wake up but what about before bed
temp well first of all the bet is for
sleeping right right so you
you know i'm in the state and lost i
studied yeah i studied in bed which was
a huge mystery
don't work in bed yeah 64 degrees is
actually the optimal
yeah i heard 65 but definitely much
colder than people normally
have if you're gonna buy a mentor in
anything before even you have a
business coach and i am a business coach
i'm working against myself
have a sleep coach you know literally
because if you have alternative routines
i call my sleep coach and say i'm going
to hong kong for 36 hours
here's when i land oh wow should i
should i pay for a bed
right right and if not should i pay for
bed when i land should i sleep right
away should i stay
up eat when should i eat it's a really
big deal when should you work out again
also open up the shades yeah so like
darkness and light so
there's a lot that they can help you
with oh sure right
even for like firmness of pillow snoring
is another thing that i've been tested
for just
all types of different things but i want
to
be productive and accessible well they
definitely there's plenty of evidence
that shows that sleep is where you
also are able to stay healthy from like
illnesses right so whether it's the cold
or anything like that like it's sick
no people don't like me to tell you that
stay well just from i don't
i'm like a cockroach i like i'm a
carrier i guess but i don't get sick
and it drives my employees crazy because
i'm very non
because you get a ton of [ __ ] done
and you're never sick and they always
have the irish flu on like a friday
after a bit right
that's different though that's different
um but it's so interesting because sleep
has changed my
my life yeah it really has and i really
encourage people to study it
and then study other things that you're
doing the last thing applies right to
that
which i had this real confusion about
being present
and you know people would always say oh
be present and yeah like i never really
had to answer what did you even know
what that meant back then
did you really have a thought to it i i
thought i just knew it so like why would
i give it thought then people started
asking me
you know what does it mean and i was
like i don't really know and i started
thinking like kung fu panda you know
today's the gift you know the turtle's
telling the panda yeah that's why we
call it the president
like what does that mean what i realized
it mean to me
was a really pragmatic thing and i tell
people all the time
you have to do things now if you ask
yourself no matter what it is
can i do this now you save at least
twice as much time by doing something
now and you're exponentially more
successful
high five i agree like when someone
asked for something or somebody i'm like
let's just do it right now yeah
whether it's like somebody wants a
picture and i'm like let's just do it
right now
somebody needs me to let's just do it
right now because more than anything
it's because i'll forget
but also it's just done it's just like
and that sits on your
conscience and you're like you like you
kind of remember and then you feel
guilty and then you really feel guilty
when you forget
yeah and then i have an added thing i
have a do it now folder
so if i can't do something now i put it
i either texted myself or
email folder then what happens is when
i'm stood in my calendar i put a portion
of the day
to go through my do it now folder and i
prioritize by what's important
so many people confuse urgency with
important if something's just
urgent but not important like hey your
wife needs milk or i need my laundry by
tomorrow because i'm speaking and i need
that suit
yeah that is urgent yeah not very
important so you delegate
anything that's urgent and not important
so i literally go through
and delegate because i just email to the
person that i'm delegating it to
and what happens is one as a salesperson
that killed me
is you know the guy that says really big
deal call me
on this date it could be three weeks and
you put it in your calendar and it's
always sitting
monday starts and it's on thursday like
oh my god i'm gonna close that deal
i've been working on it i've been
waiting three weeks somehow and i've
done this several times by thursday
you forget to call the guy like that
thing like the
most important thing i've done it and
i'm like how
how did i forget to do that you
literally you're at the end of the day
going
how did because i was stuck in not doing
it now not being
important and urgent not having a
codified list to knock things out
write things down huge huge helper so
maybe you could i think it would be
really
really helpful if you could maybe maybe
give
everyone some direction as to
what they could do to um
set themselves on
a higher vibrational path for their life
and now it's for their life right
because i'm sure that when your
business got better personal personal
helps but like it's all it's
all in the same it's all happening at
the same time so
you know maybe there's something you can
you can give some advice on
i think awareness-wise you know i'm on a
happiness crusade uh
i read a report that the average
american is happy 15 days
a year that's [ __ ] number one uh cause
of death for people under 50 is suicide
so wow um i've been studying it it
really means a lot to me but because
i think that people just have to have
one mindset what if every person you saw
everything that you did
statistically you got better at doing
one thing asking yourself
how can i be kind to my future self so
it's really silly but i'll walk in
somewhere
and i'll say oh this person how can i be
kind to my future self
what is it i could do i come i used to
pass people on the street
that's not kind to my future self just
take a minute you know
go ahead do you see them again exactly
whatever you need them
piece of trash i pick it up every single
thing i do is on a goal or potential of
being kind to my future self
and in actuality it's a very selfish
thing when you think about the words i'm
being
kind to my future self but in order to
do that i'm actually just doing good
deeds
right what if they need you and you are
the one that can make something happen
for them
exactly and you can actually teach other
people
my crusade is i i really wanted to
figure out how to make 100 billion
dollars like besos and i've challenged
myself economically to figure out
the math of it and i haven't been able
to do it but the one thing i have
mathematically figured out that and i
have the platform to do it
is what if i could find a thousand
people like a danica patrick
who could empower a thousand people to
empower a thousand people
yeah that would be a thousand times a
thousand a million a million times and
thousands of billion
and if i i could teach these things that
we're talking about just to empower them
to be happy
what if a billion people on earth were
happy 365 days a year not every moment
the entire earth would change in time
one particle of light
overcomes millions of darkness there
yeah the so many diseases would leave so
it would be an extraordinary place it
would stop fighting i
actually believe maybe i'm crazy but
like
as crazy as anything i've ever thought i
have the math of it and i really believe
i have the power of the relationships
the platform
to find a thousand danica patrick's that
really believe in this
and it's only two levels down right if i
can find a thousand of you
all i need to do a thousand times a
thousand is a million
all i need to do is teach you to teach a
thousand and then the other
thousand and we get to a billion people
and the math
is so easy in my mind i'm like i can
actually do that
and i'm not in a hurry what if it's only
20 people a year
right it'll take me 50 years you know i
got to live to 101 to do that but i
think i can do more than yeah than that
in the year
yeah because of the platform that we
have so that's where my mindset is
being kind to my future self teaching
people to be kind to their future self
trying to statistically get better every
day of just
being kind and creating positive energy
yeah
and it's really hard but it's really
simple
the one thing i always think is um you
know because i i mean like i fall into
the trap of judging or
of course in you know um or being angry
about something whether that's the way
they drive on the road or
see how slow they respond to me or
something yeah sure but they're
but but honestly i mean when you start
to meet enough people from enough
countries and enough
enough situations you realize that
everybody's really doing the best they
can for the most part i mean there's
some
there's some evil souls but they're not
that many of those
most people are doing the best they can
from their level of consciousness and to
have patience with that
yeah i still would like to teach them
all how to drive but yeah
[Laughter]
well well coming from the greatest
driver oh well
one of them hopefully thank you so much
i think that's very inspirational and
i think you've overachieved today on
your thousand wow when this comes out
and people listen to it this will
be very powerful as it's powerful for me
just sitting here so
this is the point thank you pinch myself
week just being here with you and all
the other things i've gotten to do with
the launch of my book
and tv shows that i'm doing but this is
the it really all started with you it
started with meeting you at elevator
pitch and
you know you being a passionate person
and you being so kind
and and sitting and doing your podcast
that day and they're yelling at us
to stop after almost 30 minutes and i'm
like shut up go away we're having so
much fun
you're awesome so thank you intense oh
yeah successful podcast well that's you
know my mission would be to get people
to go deeper right you've got to try
because there's no
you know to grow you have to go through
that pain so it's gonna sometimes it's
not necessarily gonna be physically
painful but maybe emotionally or maybe
a pain in the ass but it's part of the
growth and so
thank you for being a part of that
you're awesome thanks david thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you